all right so these right wing stories
about people crying they've become so
ridiculous that they're essentially
parodies of themselves
I'm not really going to show you one of
those here from Republican senator Ted
Cruz although it certainly reminded me
of it but this actually is one of these
stories about people coming up to me the
prototypical one that Trump tells is oh
you know with the people that arrested
last week he said the people that
arrested me were crying when they
arrested me okay the the sort of subtext
of this particular story from Ted Cruz
is that whenever he lands at different
airports police just flock to him police
flock to him and they just all support
him so much and this is again it's
dubious it's always dubious when Ted
Cruz in this clip he's gonna say it's
like dozens a dozen police officers or
whatever it's probably happened at some
point
that a police officer came up to Ted
Cruz and gave him a patch or whatever
crew says here but there's a very
significant
political utility to these particular
types of stories so listen to this one
and then we're going to talk about it
the most striking place to fly into is
Chicago I land at Chicago O'Hare Airport
I am with some regularity met by 10 12
15 uniformed police officers who come
they shake my hand they give me patches
I've got my office patches of the
Chicago PD that that are displayed in my
office because those cops are so under
assault but were they crying when they
met you sir okay so it what is the point
of these stories at this point in time
the point is that it would be extremely
dangerous and damaging to Republicans
for it to become known that there is
plenty of military and law enforcement
that supports Democrats and in fact when
you look at the 2020 presidential
election one of the interesting things
about yes the military leans right
there's no question about that but one
of the interesting things about the
military vote in 2020
is that it was one of the highest levels
of support for the Democratic candidate
that Joe Biden received from members of
the military than had been seen by
democrats for a very long time I don't
remember the exact numbers they don't
really matter but the point is compared
to past elections it was a higher level
of support
and this is all
because Republicans want and to some
degree have obtained a monopoly on
certain elements of political discourse
Law and Order or As Trump once called it
law and Auto
auto insurance very very important issue
but something else altogether
Republicans use this Law and Order
messaging we are for Law and Order when
it comes to immigration when it comes to
Street crime when it comes to
demonstrations when it comes to all of
these different things and they portray
themselves as the Arbiters of Law and
Order and so they do that to appeal to
voters who prioritize safety and who
prioritize security Now understand
that it's total BS it's complete and
total utter BS the reality is Law and
Order means we want our political
enemies targeted but we don't want to be
targeted when we do the same things Law
and Order means we support the police
except when it's the D.C Capital police
trying to beat off rioters on January
6th of 2021 or we Law and Order except
when it's not Law and Order no one is
above the law except when it's Trump and
then why isn't he Above the Law he
should be above the law that's the
messaging and if it became known that
they aren't actually the party of Law
and Order would be very damaging
nationalism and patriotism another
element of this supposedly so remember
it's supposedly
pro-police narrative the Republican
Party often uh uh it translates or
utilizes stated support for police in
the military as a point of national
pride they must love the country more
because they support police and police
support them what that doesn't really
make any sense or the military again and
particularly when there's a crisis or a
conflict or a war
as we saw during the Iraq War under
George W Bush's presidency that can
actually be pretty useful it Taps into
feelings of loyalty and Duty among many
in the country and then thirdly this
narrative about how much police loved
Ted Cruz
it's to draw distinction with Democrats
you emphasize you know we we have the
support of police and members of the
military and that's because Democrats
are weak or they're unpatriotic or
whatever and if Democrats are seen as
being critical of law enforcement then
that contrast is even even more useful
so it's another one of these they come
up to me with tears in my eyes stories
from Cancun Ted Cruz but it is part of a
much larger political uh area of
political strategy that if Republicans
were to lose and they should lose it
because it's all completely fabricated
would be very damaging to them